Welcome to Elementary Statistics.
We're really excited
to have you on board.
My name's Katie, and
I'm the one who will be explaining most
of the concepts throughout this course.
I'll also be doing a lot of drawing and
a lot of writing to help you understand
the content as much as possible.
In each of the 16
lessons in this course,
you'll learn new methods to describe and
analyze data.
Each lesson builds on the concepts you
learned before, so as you progress
through the course, try to get a good
grasp of the material before moving on.
But if it turns out you need a review,
no big deal.
You can easily go back and re-watch
the videos and redo the exercises.
What do I mean by exercises?
Each lesson consists of short
instructional videos where I explain
cool stats stuff and
guide your thinking.
But we want you to make
breakthroughs on your own.
So instead of just telling you a fact or
formula, I'll ask a quiz.
A quiz, or exercise, same thing,
is not there for us to judge you or
to impact your grade.
It's there for your own benefit,
to make you think.
At Udacity, we believe that the chance
to think about something from your own
unique perspective is a powerful
learning opportunity.